Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan, although you may
know me from across the internet as Rawkode.
And today we have an episode of Clustered.
Clustered is a,
I don't know, actually. Clustered is an experience
where we have two members or two teams
join us with some broken clusters
and will attempt to share their Kubernetes
knowledge with us as they debug and fix,
hopefully fix those clusters.
Before we begin today, there's a little bit
of housekeeping and thank yous.
First, I need to thank Teleport. They've been
sponsoring and supporting Clustered
since the very beginning, and we've been using
Teleport in every single episode to help share,
pair and fix clusters.
So if you wanna say hello to Teleport
and support the show, please check out Rawkode.liteleport.
It keeps them happy, it keeps me happy,
and it keeps things ticking along.
Also, Equinix Medal have been sponsoring by providing
all of the hardware.
Every cluster, and clustered is, a multi node
bare metal Kubernetes
cluster
hand rolled by my own artisanal bash code
and some Pulumi sprinkled in too. So thank
you to Equinix Metal. It's great hardware. I
love using it every week, and I really
appreciate it.
Alright. Lots of chats, lots of hellos in
the chats, and I'll get to them in
just a minute. But first, I wanna introduce
today's first
team.
Hello, team at Giant Swarm. How's it going?
Hello.
Hey. How are you? Hello, everybody.
He's all excited?
Oh, yes. Yes. Yeah. Of course, you are.
Alright.
Alright. Let's start with you, Marcus. We'll go
around clockwise. Can you all introduce yourselves, say
hello, and then we'll take it from there.
Hey,
everyone. I'm Marcus. I'm a platform engineer here
at Giant Swarm, and I've been with company
about six months now. So fairly new. I'm
quite looking forward to this.
Yeah.
Hey. I'm Fuya. I'm a virtual product here
at Transform. A bit longer than six months
or a bit more than seven years now
with Transform.
And,
yeah, we're looking forward to how to fix
a really meanly broken cluster.
And hello, everybody. I'm Christian, SRE at Transform.
Been here for a couple of years now.
Let's do this.
Alright.
Let's get my screen share up. So I
have already given you all access to the
other cluster broken by team at Wildlife Studios
who will be joining on us in roughly
forty five minutes time.
The you got forty five minutes. I set
it to forty six. That gives us one
minute to make sure things are alright, but
we do have a time we have to
keep track of progress. We have access to
all the nodes. I will
bravely going to use the SSH client for
today.
And I will open a session on Wildlife
Studios Control Plane one. If you could all
please join the session,
type echo hello, anything that you want, just
to let me know you're there and then
we'll get things underway.
But remember to find the session ID and
join. Please don't open your own one.
If we can't watch you type, it's not
very fun.
Alright. There's a first of all. Thank you.
Alright.
You're all in. Perfect.
Well, good luck. Off you go.
Cool.
Marcus, you're driving. Right?
I am. Yes.
So before we actually get going, we're gonna
pull in a few
tools to help us debug.
Tube control? You bring in your own Tube
control?
Yeah. You you don't trust anything, do you?
Nope.
Nope. Alright. Kube control,
j q, k nine, entity control.
Cool.
Nice. I've never seen this subscript like that
before, but I like it.
We can share it afterwards.
Cool.
Okay. So We have a control plane. Access,
so that's that's a good That's nice.
We do. I always worry when there's a
control plane in case people forgot to break
a cluster.
Oh, yeah. Canines doesn't doesn't
work very well on
Cool. So
Not running. Actually, back off. Let's have a
look.
When running commands with long output, I would
encourage you to use less so that we
have the same scroll settings instead of scrolling
in your own tower. Just FYI.
Sure.
Cool. So
I also just wanna point out, this is
the first cluster in three months where everything
has been running
when I gave the cluster to you. You
know?
I've been improving my my process. Very worrisome
to me. But
yeah.
The app is not running. It's crash proofing.
There is m s r e ingress. There
was an m s r e ingress in
one hours. Right?
Yeah. There was. Right?
Was it? Yeah. There was. Yeah. Yes.
There was. Did you did you remove it?
So
that doesn't work right. It
takes it with status code zero, so
maybe the image is
not what we expect it to be.
Anyway, we have to bump to v two,
so let's do it straight away. Right?
Cool. Yeah. Why not?
Let's do that.
Clean the password.
Oh.
Oh, wow. It does not like that.
Yeah. There have been issues with them before.
That's not nice.
Okay.
So we're doing this old school one.
I mean, you can try installing
Nano. I can switch to the web interface.
That may help.
Whatever. What do you what do you all
think?
It looked okay on the web interface. But
Yeah. It's it's just the CLI that gets
the weird issue with them.
Okay. Now I'll tell you what. I'll I'll
switch over to the
You can use QCTL set image if you
want.
Image
deployment slash deployment name.
Yeah. We might need to remove the the
ID fields there. There's a container ID and
an image ID.
Right? Oh, no. That they they'll be updated.
Right? They'll be updated. Yeah. If you if
you change the image, the image ID will
be updated. Yeah. Right.
Oh, sorry. Yeah.
You also need the container name, which is
cluster d.
Clustered.
Yeah. I never remember the same image syntax.
Mhmm.
According to the documentation, you need
container name equals image name.
As in
No. No. No. No. It was already Clusters
equal.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Sorry. Yeah. Thank you.
Okay.
Let's see what happens now.
Hopefully, it's pulling an image.
Let me see.
Let me describe it.
Yeah.
See where it's hanging.
Redness probe and redness probe.
Is my timer broken? Okay.
Surely, that's been more than one minute.
Yes. Let's
check the probes on the on the.
Yeah. I'm gonna switch over to the web,
though, so I can use the
use VIM because otherwise, this is gonna get
quite messy.
Yeah. Oh, okay. Okay. The loudness probe is
clearly wrong. Also, the readiness probe is clearly
clearly wrong.
Mhmm.
Cool.
That's not is that showing alright for you?
It's alright. I can Yeah. I'll I'll open
another session. Yeah. I'll join the session too.
That way, when we do use them, we
can at least see it on the web,
and then I'll pop back. Yeah. Yeah.
Cool. So I'm just gonna get rid of
the probes.
Completely get behind them.
I worked hard on the probes. But before
hold on before you do that because it
I saw something weird in the describe in
the describe. Okay. Can you describe the path
so you can so we can see it
together?
If you scroll up a little bit to
the probes definition.
Maybe it's normal. It's just me. You need
to paper for less to show that on
the screen. Oh,
Chat when you see him. Where is it?
There we go.
Yeah. So they're missing
IP address, but it defaults to Rawkode. Right?
So it should work. Yeah.
Yeah. That should be fine.
So any objections when you just get rid
of them? No. Just get rid of them.
It's fine.
I mean, that's what I do on prod.
Yeah. Why not?
Exactly. Yeah. We need that.
We know this pro.
It is running. It's running.
You want me to test it? It doesn't
no. I've just tried. Wait. Oh, what was
that? It was me. Sorry.
No. We haven't we haven't got access yet.
What's the note for it? 30,000.
You can curl it on that machine, I
guess. 30000.
Right?
Yeah. It's still crashing.
Oh, it's still crashing.
Yes.
Oh, It's restarting. Okay.
Any jobs?
Pods and bugs changed. They will be killed
and recreated.
I just turned on my timer off. I
have no idea what's going on with that
timer.
It went back up again.
Alright.
Let's let's start having a look what we've
got.
And so
I'm gonna check if we've got any webhooks
in play to start with. Mhmm.
So there's none. That's that's good.
What if we check the Kubelet locks in
the node where the pod is running?
So which one is that then? There's a
worker two.
So
if we we switch over to the worker
two, David?
Of course.
Session
opened.
K. In the meantime, I can check on
the control plane if there's network policies or
any cron jobs.
Thank you.
Cool. Cron jobs.
Which one was it?
JF6Q2.
There's another one there.
So do wanna give this or the bad
news?
Both?
No. Well, there isn't any good news. I
never actually added any logging to the clusters
application.
So it could be working. It could not
be working. Cool. Alright.
I mean Alright. Let's switch back. It doesn't
look like it's working. Right? Let's let's just
I'll try I'll load it up here because
we're not we're not done that yet. So
thirty after three.
It's it's not returned as a thing.
Well, join the control plane or worker two?
I'm back on the control plane.
Alright. This is a here.
So
I believe the port's correct
from what I remember. Is is was it
8080?
In
the Yeah?
Yeah.
In a whale, but yeah.
Resources look fine. There's not really anything else
going on here.
Mark Ross is in the chat saying, remember,
there are hints in home if required, but
I I I don't think you're there yet.
It's too early for that.
I mean, there's other stuff from this deployment
spec you could remove that could potentially cross
actually back off. Right?
Mean, you've deleted the probes, I would delete
one other thing just to be sure.
So get rid of the resource limits.
Good call.
Because
my code is perfect, so we don't need
resource limits. We don't need probes. It just
works.
Sure.
I mean, it's running the Rust, so it
can't crash.
Yeah. That looks healthier.
Access.
Check services, Mary.
No. It's still crushing.
Is it?
Yeah. It is.
Alright. It is crashing.
So it took about thirty seconds before the
first crash. Does that
give you a hint?
Rest period is at thirty seconds. Right?
So maybe there's no pressure.
So that last one's been modified.
I think that was me.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't want I want you chasing a
red herring. That that was me fixing KubePit.
Okay. My my favorite bug that I have
reported this week, though, if you open the
KubePit manifest again, this will just take, like,
one second.
The spelling of Prometheus.
Oh,
wow. Prometheus.
So I I got this a a pull
request to.
Hopefully, that gets there. But there you go.
That's why I had to modify that file
because I spelled it correctly, and it was
crashing.
Nice. Okay.
Alright. So we have a pod that continues
to crash.
We do.
At least Postgres is happy.
It is.
Check service for post custom.
Alright. What have we got here? So
absolute.
You seem to be confined in your search
to the Kubernetes API.
Maybe
maybe look on the notes if there's anything
else.
Yeah. I mean, I I don't know. I
I'm I'm speculating as much as much as
you all are.
But at this point, I I think I'd
start looking beyond Kubernetes,
potentially.
Okay.
Back to worker two.
Yes. Let me just move it to another
worker.
Could do. Yeah. What
do you think there's something specifically wrong with
worker two?
It's still in worker two, so let's stick
to worker two. Yes. Yeah. Let's switch, please,
Yeah.
Ah, okay. You move. Oh, you're you're going
to try and reschedule that putt then.
Yes, Stefan. You're right that a pod without
logs should not run-in any cluster. I do
apologize.
I I will add logging for the next
episode.
You are as welcome. Right?
Let's wait for thirty seconds.
There we go. Yeah. There you go. I'll
go. Good.
Alright. Do we do we wanna switch over
to that node then and and have a
look, see what's going on there?
Yep.
Alright.
So worker one?
Yes, please.
So it does the same on worker one
and worker two. I looked at emptying the
crown and didn't find anything.
Alright.
One of your colleagues is in the chat.
Hey, Joe. Thirty seconds feels like network
network timeout.
Oh, it's okay.
Do we think it's silly in that?
Well, why don't we spin up another
container
and we try to ping,
I don't know, the API server from the
internal service IP and stuff like that to
check if networking works?
Mhmm.
But would networking cause a crash loop back
off?
It shouldn't. Right? If your image
is trying to reach
something else and can't, maybe it crashes.
Oh, my application does nothing until the first
request comes in.
Okay.
K. So something something requesting something from the
from the application?
I mean, you could wait for it to
come back online and then nobody touch anything
and see what happens.
The do nothing approach to debugging.
So oh, you can't see when I highlight
things, can you? So there's a there's a
line in here.
Hold on. Let me
anyway,
that line.
Does anybody know what what that is?
Those
oh.
Error syncing pod skipping failed to so it's
failed to start the container.
Check container deconfiguration on the one.
Yeah. Hold on.
Where are we for container d?
Right. You have twenty minutes left.
Okay. So we've got it. It's showing that
that's that's good at least.
Oh, that's
interesting.
Emissary showing is not ready.
I mean, just ignore Emissary for now just
in case.
I'm sure I fixed it in all the
clusters, but
but but I just I don't want you
to chase that one. I feel weird the
cluster says ready because the Kubelet logs that
you pulled out suggested that I wasn't able
to actually start the container. So I'm a
little bit confused.
But that does appear to be a running
custom. Otherwise, there
Yeah.
Wait. The deployment said something about
progress deadline seconds having
right?
That usually just happens
if
if the resource set like, if the deployment
can't be updated.
So there are hints. Can we Remember
if we need to look at the first
hint.
What do we what do we think?
There's a comment from Russell in the chat
who spotted a sleep 20 in the process
output.
There's a nice thread for that.
There is. Yeah.
It's a pause shim.
What where are you looking? Oh, you got
it? Okay.
Yeah. Hold on.
Yeah.
Maybe let's process the information as a tree
and see if you can find a hierarchy.
Yes.
Somebody remind me what the Maybe e f
might be a good one.
A f.
Oh,
Sorry.
That's
That's not enough. P s
a u e f.
I can never remember. A u x e
f. Yeah. I know.
Keep adding letters. Oh, there we go. There
we go. Right.
Okay.
So
so
Yeah. That looks suspicious.
It does.
But it looks like it's just in the
root directory.
Assuming it's not in that container, of course.
But I would I would check the root
fail system.
What if we try to shadow the part
in the control plane?
Yeah. Could try that.
Can we switch back to the the control
plane node?
Yep.
Done.
Cool.
Copy and paste, I think. So what is
it you're trying to do just now?
Move it to the master node, to the
control panel.
Yes. Yeah. That was the plan.
That's the hard way of scheduling it there.
Just drop a note name in there. Come
on. Yeah. Yeah. Let's do that. Let's do
that.
Where is
And it's like isn't it?
No. Not name.
Was it not name? Yeah. You can just
do not name and then do
wildlife studios dashboard control plane one. Whatever the
name is. I can't remember.
It's wildlife studios dash control dash plane dot
dash one.
Yes.
You may have to put it as not
under
spec template spec node name. It would be
spec template
node name.
No.
It would be on the pod.
What'd I do there?
Yeah. Try there. I can't remember.
Just keep pacing the place, please, to the
work.
No. I I I I guess that's the
ten minute. Schedule. Because
we're not scheduling the deployment. We're scheduling the
pods.
Yes. It's in in there. Yes.
Not there, but inside spec.
It was inside spec.
That was right, actually. That's what documentation says.
Hey. Come on, chat. Tell us what I'm
doing. Where where do we put on name?
They
they always fix it for me.
The Rawkode scheduler. Yeah. Russell's seen this this
before.
Where's your customer?
There
we go.
You may just have to delete the pod
to force the reschedule.
No. It didn't update.
Run get pods with a dash of weight.
Where is it?
The the the new name's gone.
There we go.
Yes. There now. Cool.
Running.
It restarted already. Oh, that was That
was fast.
Yeah. I would maybe check a hint.
You got somewhere between ten to fifteen minutes
left.
Okay. Yeah. So oh, wow. It's a it's
a lot.
That that does not fill me with confidence.
It lives next to your application,
and it's usually unnoticed.
Is it the sidecar?
I guess it's the pause container based on
the things we've seen so far. Right?
But you won't see that in the deployment
spec.
I've I've just checked the pod now. There's
no there's no other
container. It's just it's just the one.
Did they replace the pause container
in in the API server complex?
Yeah. Good call.
Check if you see it.
Not.
Wrote it.
Dimension of pause in the API server.
It's not a it's not a Kubla setting,
is it?
It
might be. It might be.
Kubla or a container d.
Pretty sure it's not in the CLI.
It might be Kubler.
But the container d could be configured to
pull
different image.
I don't know how nasty
Layout Live Studios would be.
Oh, there's no container d.
So if
you run system
control cat kubelet, it'll show you where all
the configs are.
Like
look at that. Oh, wow. Okay. Cool.
So there's the FireLab duplicate config.
There's the
flags
dot ENV and
the default kubelet config. There's three things there
you probably wanna look at.
Yeah. So when I look at the
check this one out first, I think.
So nothing in there is jumping
out at me.
What's the next one? Let's have a look
at the environment
flags.
Mhmm. Yep.
So there's the there's that pause image.
Yeah. But that
looks Seems that snow. Right?
How long we got left?
Around ten minutes.
Let's pop another hand.
Yeah. That's That's it.
I'm stumped. I I have I I don't
know what we should be looking at just
yet.
Yeah.
We know that. Right? So we're definitely it's
something that there was a paused container. It's
definitely something
Run a container,
the dump config.
Oh, hold on. There
we go.
Oh, yeah. Close that. Oh.
That's that's not what I wanted.
Oh, come on.
Config dump. Yeah.
Okay. There's none.
They could have pre pulled a paused container
to the machine that's been painted.
Marcus says there's three things broken on this.
Let's just pop the hints on part one
and see if we can get into part
two.
Okay. So check part two. Hint one dot
two. Right? We've got to that yet. Two.
Yeah. Okay.
Oh, my gosh. Come on. We know.
Yeah. Mark was just saying Yeah. You have
tampered with the pause image. So if you
remove that from
the Move it from the notes.
Oh,
god. Does anybody know how do that with
container d?
Cry control image r m try
control image s l s first.
Yep. And then image r m and
yeah. There you go. Two of them. There's
a two meg and a 300 kilobyte and
a 200 kilobyte.
I would just start deleting all those image
IDs.
So they're still there.
That's not the right plan.
Oh, RMI. RMI.
Cool. That's that one gone.
Oops. Well, that's the only one you should
have to remove. So it should now pull
a tagged version.
So try deleting your cluster pod.
Maybe?
Hey.
Let's see if it works.
Doesn't work. Nope. Nope. Doesn't work.
Alright. Next problem.
Check endpoints.
Okay.
The pod is working now because if you
curl in the pod itself, it's responding. So
that's something.
Cool. So it's now just a case of
the
ingress not working.
There's no ingress?
Is it No. It's not ingress. Sorry. It's
it's no.
Yep. I ran a curl on worker one,
and it's timing out. So
At dash capital l?
Yeah. I can't I can't type, it seems.
Note to pad also works.
So maybe it's a service problem.
Mhmm. Mark,
the data chat says no IP tables or
has
been used on this cluster.
You got six more minutes.
Are there any Kubernetes ways to restrict network
traffic?
Not a bunch There no there was no
network policies in there. This is a Cilium
cluster. Check the Cilium ones. I checked the
check the Cilium ones too. Yeah.
The cluster wide and the
Yep.
PCMP.
And that goes the idea.
Yeah.
Let this
is calling the service working?
Oh.
Awesome.
Has a contract map. Right?
Is it? Let's look at that.
Let's check how it's configured. Maybe the
two proxy
or the the the node port implementation.
Thing is, I
don't know enough about Cillium to know whether
this is
default or not.
So if I remember correctly, there's this enable
policy default lane, which I think may
block everything by default.
We can set that to never. You can
set that to yep. Which might be a
good first step.
What's it called?
Because this is Kubernetes,
we have to rotate the pot.
When the Cillium pods come back up, they
do provide a CLI. You can do Cillium
status and save one of those pods.
Maybe worth doing. Oh, yeah.
Cool. Yeah.
Shouldn't there be three city imports?
I have no idea.
Alright. It's a.
Oh, is it?
And so, yeah, that probably should be then.
Did you exec into the Cilium pod?
No. Checking the the data set first.
Not seeing anything.
Last minute.
It's not running on the on the
the control plane node.
What's the container called?
Cilium agent.
You can just do Cilium status, and it'll
run it in a default container.
Okay. But delete dash agent and then just
space status.
Oh, I'm it was called Celium.
We just run bash again, so you don't
Yeah. We're gonna have to add a dash
IT, though.
Well, like, it's got bash.
Alright. Well, we are all out of town.
That
was a tough one.
Well
Alright.
I'll
let you jump
off the call. I'll get the way I'll
let you just people in. They can tell
us what they did, and then we'll take
a look at your cluster. But thank you.
I mean, that that that's stumped me. And
Marcus has been on that before, and he's
always lethal. So
but
good job. I'll just cut this on a
bit. Yeah.
Thanks.
Alright. Let's get Wilder Studios involved.
Hello.
How are you?
Hey. What's up?
That was tough. Can you hear me? Hey.
Yeah. Yep. Yep.
That was Oh, yeah. Yeah. Sorry for that,
man. Sorry for that. It was fun. It
was fun to watch, though.
We we thought we left some crumbles along
the way. You know? You know, the the
sleep process and and all those things. But,
I mean, these guys made an amazing work.
It wasn't easy. It wasn't easy at all
to understand what was happening.
Alright. Well, why don't you well, back before
you tell us what happened in that cluster,
just wanna both introduce yourselves, say hello, and
then we'll get started.
Cool. We I can't hear Leonardo.
Oh.
Yeah. We can't hear you, my friend.
Maybe he's muted, but I can introduce myself
in the meantime. Hi, everyone. My name is
Marcos Niels.
I've been here before, so we are, like,
Internet friends with David. Hopefully, we can meet
each other in person, David, at some conference
or something soon.
And now can you hear me? At Wildlife's
We can hear you now. Yep. That's better.
Nice.
So
I work at Wildlife Studios with Leo. We
are part of the engineering team. We do
a little bit of Kubernetes
gaming stuff as well. Of course, we are
hiring people if you want to join us.
It's an amazing company. And we are here
to have fun, learn Kubernetes,
and share our knowledge with the the rest
of the world.
Thank you. Leonardo, do wanna introduce yourself? I'm
I'm Leonardo. Everybody
calls me here.
It's my surname. And I've been on YDLi
for two years now, I think. Went to
to two years on March, if I'm not
mistaken.
And yeah. I've always liked it to be
an SRE, and that's it.
Awesome.
Alright. So quite a bit the lag, I
think. Let me move my screens here to
the side. Yeah. It's a little bit. Oh,
there we go. That seems to be better.
Much better now. So tell us what happened
to that cluster that pure cluster.
Nice. So so
I Go ahead, Daniel. Started to we started
to to mess with Cilium because we use
Cilium here at Wildlife.
And I know I think it's more of
our expertise.
But at that at some point, Marco said,
like, we have a lot of problems with
network already. So let's move to another another
let's break another thing.
And he fought on the POS containers
itself.
But two problems were related to
container d and c and I, and the
other one was the POS container.
Yeah. Tinting the POS container was pretty nasty.
But then messing with Cilium. I mean, nobody
knows how to configure Cilium. I just always
trust it works.
Exactly.
So to give them, like, more
concrete things about what we did is, like,
initial first, we disabled Cilium. Right? We
downscale the demo set. Right? So Yeah. And
we renamed there's another deployment that is called
c Cilium operator, which is the operator,
and we renamed that deployment to Cilium.
So they think that the demo set was
up, but instead the operator was up, which
was not providing any connectivity to the cluster.
Right? Yeah. I thought those were very names
of the daemon set. Doesn't have the node
names on it, but, you know, they were
we were just running out of time to
start debugging that. But it that's tricky as
weird. I was like, that's not a daemon
set because they have a very special name.
Exactly.
We also what is some parts on the
we also configured some parts on the ceiling
itself so it wouldn't
route for the service. Right?
And
when they
if they discovered about this the demo set,
when they started the demo set, it would
Citi would it would configure itself
and
almost everything would work. Almost. Only the the
application wouldn't.
Like, card DNS would and the Kubernetes itself
would port to port connectivity,
but not the server itself. So, yeah, there
there there is also Yeah. The configuration of
this config map that we did.
The the interesting part of this is that
if you
downscale CDU, the notes are gonna become not
ready. But as you saw, the notes were
ready. Right? Mhmm. So what we did instead
is, like, we tricked basically the QLED to
believe that the note was ready when CDU
was not up, basically. So that's why they
believed everything was working
where
on like, we actually put a a CNI
configuration, like a dummy CNI configuration file on
the on the host.
Like, yeah, basically,
making making Kubernetes believe that everything was working
when it wasn't working.
But we didn't change any any like, besides
the the post image, we didn't change any
outside the the normal configuration
of Kubernetes. Right? We didn't Of Kubernetes. Yeah.
System or yeah. Exactly. Everything was Kubernetes based.
Wow. That is that is clustered on hard
mode. That is harsh. They're taking the CNI
configurations for the pods already and then
alright. Well, let's see what Giant Swarm have
in store for you. So
screen share is up. I have connected and
started a session on their control plane node.
So if you could please join a session
and give me an echo hello or anything
to let me know that you're there, and
best of luck. Let me get the link.
Thank you very much. So is gonna be
is gonna be driving. I'm gonna be taking
the chat and,
you know, helping from far away.
Sounds good. Let me open the the machines
here.
The control plane's here. So hello.
Oh,
I think you started your own session instead
of joining main.
Oh, okay. Let me it's on clusters on
activity
Activity. Active sessions. Yep.
Giant swarm, control plane, joint session. Yep. Perfect.
I'm the leader as well.
Hello.
Awesome. That's it? Yep. Nice.
Best of luck.
K.
Let's do this. Oh, sorry. Sorry, Max.
Sorry. Go ahead.
Let's start with the alias
configuration.
CTL.
We need your code, Scott. We're gonna be
looking at the tail.
CD
configuration admin.
So
oh, there is no
there is no complete here. Right?
No. They it seems like they they already
messed with the q c QCDL binary.
Let's So
I would I would
I would do an APT reinstall because I
I think it's gonna be faster than trying
to fix it.
Yeah.
It looks like a Wise words.
Download.
Let me do just
You can do an APT, I believe. APT
install, reinstall QCTL should work. Yeah. The flag
is install dash dash reinstall.
Oh,
James. So
Let me Probably just We have something in
the, yeah, in the in the path. Right?
Oh, shit.
Not sure. Let me just be sure this
this okay. Maybe.
Which
cubes do you know?
Remove that one
and try again.
Okay. Now it should be the first one.
Yeah.
Yeah. Like, the the batch basically. Secsorts. Yeah.
So we can Okay. So we don't have
the connectivity to the server? You haven't reexported
the KubeConfig in your new batch. Oh, you're
right.
Thanks.
Oh. Do nothing to cancel it. Okay. Down.
Yeah. So the API server could be down.
Can you check if the do a PS
and see if the API server is running?
If what's running?
Do a PS and see if the API
server is running the process.
No. So it's down.
It's down. Let me check the
containers here.
Yeah. So probably they guys not here.
They changed the manifests on
Rawkode container. Right?
Yeah.
So
there is no Kube API here either. So
let's check for the manifest.
Kubernetes
manifest.
So they already changed it. Right?
Let me get this. A copy.
API server.
Yeah.
Try follow need to do a last. Right?
Yeah. So that's my follow.
Try running the maybe they disable the system,
the unified. So try doing
Yeah. So what starts these manifests?
This.
Check check the.
Status.
Cubelet.
Also, there's an error. CNI plug in not
initialized. Not initialized.
Okay.
Good thing is they're experts on Celine.
K.
Oh, ensure
lease exists.
Maybe HCD is not starting. That's why Yeah.
The service is not done.
Let me check again the Do we have
locks on on HCD?
Oh, it's not this. I want to
Oh, there's no
There's no CD either. Okay. We're on the
control plane, so it should be one at
least here.
One thing that they can do is that
they can fool the the Kubernetes to use
a different manifest configuration directory. Right? So maybe
that's why the QLED is not starting anything
because it's not actually picking the right configuration
files.
So you Actually, there's a that.
There's a QLED configuration. I believe it was
in its it ATC QLED.
Do you recall, David, where it was?
You can run system control cat QLED.
That's all the different config option. All the
different config will place you. But barleb kubelet
would be a good starting point.
Okay.
So we
need to check
the atckuberneteskubelet.com.
This is the four right here? Or
I would start with rlkubeletconfig.yaml.
Yeah. Let's go there. Oh, okay. Yeah. Okay.
I'm gonna open this on the web as
well in case I feel like VIM's coming.
So
It's not that big. Okay.
What?
What did you open?
Yeah. I think it's because
So the static port static pod path, I
think it was there. Right? So it's a
t c
Kubernetes manifests. Right? Yep.
It's right here, the static pod path.
Can you can you do something Your Kiplet
was failing. Right? Your Kiplet wasn't running.
Yeah. Exactly.
Wasn't running.
Did I start it? No. It was running.
I think it's running.
But it was failing. Yeah. There was lots
of errors. Still some errors.
Yeah. There was a a lot of errors.
But
k. Okay.
So let's can we check the logs and
restart the Kubernetes?
So So let me to the just restart
kubelet.
Yeah. Let me check the logs. Let's see
then. Do the
journals down.
I think you're gonna need to scroll up
a little bit.
It's following. Let me
let's go to the end of the file.
K.
I just complains about not filing founding
this.
Agent control plane. Failure to pull an unpack
image. There's a failure to pull an image.
Queue scheduler.
Failure to resolve reference. Seems like it can
can you try can you try to see
if you can pull the image with the
CTR?
The
those images, basically.
This queue.
Let me check here. So copy.
CPR.
IU.
It's pool. No. It's not pool.
It's
High pool, I guess, maybe?
I think it's high pool
or not. It's image. Yeah. Yeah. I'll pool.
You're right.
And this one right here.
Oh, it's resolving to local host. So they
tampered with the DNS resolution project.
So that conf?
No.
Okay. Can you do a
do you have DIMM installed to check what
k test .gc r? Yeah.
Try k test.gcr.ao.
Dot gc r .a o.
Yeah. So it's resolving to local host.
Wonderful.
So
So it's DNS. Okay.
So it's DNS.
So this could be probably
a re
system d resolved configuration.
I don't know if they installed
DNS mask or something here. It's But
I think you can go to a t
cresolve.d,
I believe it is. You are always so
mean to my clusters.
You want to go where, Marcus?
There's no Look for
resolve..d
or system d, resolve d.
No. No. No. This configuration. Yeah.
Let me check.
I'm googling this right now. It is csystemdresolve.com.
System d
resolve
Com.
Yeah. It's a
Can you do a a dig against that
server?
Maybe it's a
So I should put
any DNS
and You
can just put k test .gcr.a0space
at .ap. So
if you look at your
resolve.conf
again, the main one.
Is
resolve.conf,
you mean? Right. So the the there's
Oh, the yeah.
You mean the options there when they But
that that's okay. Right, David? Because it's using
the system d
I guess we can change this and put
Google Google thing. Right? It's the same thing
pretty much.
Because maybe they messed up with the system
d result d daemon, but
if we change it here, it should, like,
basically avoid using that.
Okay.
Okay. Nice. So let's let's start the Qubelet
now.
It's Restart
on the kubelet?
Okay.
Restart kubelet.
Now it's hidden. Yeah.
Should we start also content ID? Maybe.
I really hope they just put something on
the host file. I really, really hope it
was the host file.
Yeah. Let's see.
It's not gonna third, right, to restart everything.
Oh, it's still failing.
It's still
why why it's still Try resolving this. So
there's some configuration
next host.
Try next host.
Maybe it's a QLED configuration,
one of the different files that the QLED
has configured. Maybe they configured, like, local host
there. And
Our container d? No. There's no container configuration.
Have you looked at the host file?
On yeah. I I I did. Was there
nothing there? On the host
it was this the first one. Oh, there's
a Oh, no. There there was a
Yeah. I'm so glad it was the host
file.
It just makes it funnier. What?
Wait. That that's cool.
So when you
oh, wait. Maybe when you are trying to
beam that that yeah.
It's.
Yeah. They tried to do a type beam.
Maybe they yeah.
They're basically
fooling us there.
Just, yeah, copy the content without that line
and then echo it into the it is
a host, and that's it. Right?
You mean
you want me to get this on the
first on the first line. Right?
And whatever No. I think you need to
read to well, the other one is IPv6.
So, yeah, I think we don't care. Yeah.
Only the first line and echo that into
existing hosts.
A
sledgehammer approach, Alex. No. No. No. It's a
host. No. No. No. No. It's host. Oh.
You gotta watch it.
Yeah. No. No problem. No problem. Break more
stuff.
Sorry.
You you can take another result from another
note if you want.
No. It's just Just that name server. Yeah.
Yeah. Name server. Yeah.
Server.
Good job.
Nice. Let's see now. And now
so
pull.
Nice.
So let's see the log from starts.
Cubelets.
And let's see.
CLS.
So the kubischedule is now running.
Let's
put the
that's a l s here.
The QVAPI server
is not running.
Oh, it's running Okay. Okay.
Try doing a QVAPI server.
Do you have the Get the box. Or
if I don't get get positive, well, it
should work in in any case. Right? Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Same thing. So check the logs of
the API server now.
Where is it?
API.
Close this one.
Copy.
I think you can use autocomplete. Right?
Then we have separate range. Service cluster appearance
must be at least seen. Oh, okay. They
they mess with the,
yeah, with the IP address of the
Oh, that's configured on Kubernetes. Right?
On the manifests. On the API server. Right?
Manifest.
So
Oh, they messed up with him, so we
can't trust. Yeah. We can't trust anything that
comes with him.
Advertise.
So that seems to be okay.
Oh. There's a cross IP range line. There
you go.
Okay.
Do you have the the correct range, David?
Sixteen.
Sixteen. Sixteen.
Let me just do a
damn.
I'm going to do a set here.
Uh-oh.
No. No. Go go with BIM. We don't
know if BIM is gonna work. Right? We
didn't check that one.
Try to open it with BIM to see
if it's.
And that's all you can Why don't you
trust why don't you trust said Yeah. Why
why wouldn't you trust me? Right? It's like
the That's probably
It's already failed us. It's probably just something
in the bash profile for when you try
to open that file, I think. Okay.
I don't know. Restart you can restart the
API server now and see what happens. Oh,
it should have been restarted automatically.
Well, it might take a few moments, but,
yeah, it will it will be restarted because
the manifest changed.
Wow. Giant storm certainly did not mess with
them.
What?
Then we got a gimmick setup.
Our our troubleshooting doesn't doesn't agree on that,
probably.
I'm checking that bash profile, but then there's
that, but there's definitely something in there.
Maybe it's doing two skill kickbox. No?
There is no accept mailer.
Okay. So let's see the logs.
No. There's it's not that anymore.
Still no control plan? You can do so.
This
one right here. 04:00.
Yeah. Still not starting. Cats.
Paste.
No. It's still
it's still the same error. Let's go look.
I can arrange for at least eight IP
addresses.
It's Dash16.
Maybe it didn't it didn't restart. Try restarting
that manually. Try killing the
the API server process, and it's gonna start
again automatically.
You mean like this? Yeah. That process was
started three minutes ago, which is probably before
your change.
I
didn't find it. So
Maybe Should I just click the what? Oh,
the process ID
is there. Right?
Although that's the log fail. Oh, so maybe
they
met with the issue. Messed with the pass.
Yeah. I just found that. Try doing a
grep dot dot dot dash f.
It's pregrepped,
but it's not pregrepped for the process itself?
Yeah. Same thing. Yeah. It'll be pregrepped dash
dash f API.
Dash f API.
Like this? Oh, sorry. Yes.
No. Weird.
We don't see the process yet.
Let's see the logs again.
Logs.
Let me see if
it's the same.
Let's just kill the part, I think.
Yep.
Let's see the variable to kill it. Delete.
Grab the API
and just
see
RM
and this one.
Sorry. This one.
So now
yeah. It wasn't recreated yet.
You can force the kubelet to restart, Sandeep.
Restart
kubelet.
Power manager.
There you go. Now
server. Okay. Going up.
Just checking out. Oh,
sorry.
Alas.
No. The other one. The other one.
Shit.
URL
logs.
No no cursing here. It's complain.
I'm sorry.
You can curse if you want. Don't worry
about it.
Maybe it's for children.
That's the watershed.
What's the new one? This this one.
So
Oh, there are multiple logs, so we need
to pick the the latest one. Right?
Maybe we're seeing that in old desktop the
last time. That's why. You can always use
firewall containers firewall containers for the latest logs.
Caught some of that noise. You can grab
the ID of the container and
and just
oh, it's I don't know if you tested
this. Is that a tail in firewall containers?
And then it'll be the name of the
it'll be kubedash API.
And it's it's always the latest one.
Teo
and varlog container.
Yep. And then kubep And API. Kubep dash
API.
How do we define? We see the
it's the seven. It is the one that
start with seven. Yeah. 70. 7.
Okay.
No. That's the old one. Still the same
problem? Or is that the old one?
How do you know if that's the old
one or The 75 stamp on it was
1843.
Okay. So we should try the other one.
Try 88. Yeah.
That's the thing. Now it seems like it
can connect to Edcity. Right?
Yeah. 2379
is the city port.
Try checking the Edcity
docs maybe.
Is etcd even up?
Doesn't appear to be let's
check why.
Manifest.
Last
Okay.
Image full policy always. The image seems to
be okay, I believe.
List
okay. Client URLs. The port is okay.
Does it appear on
CTR? I
don't think so.
Or else it would appear on the No.
It's in log out there.
Yeah. It doesn't.
But it's applying every manifest on that folder?
Yeah. It's applying. Right? It should be applying
every manifest. Yeah.
So
maybe we can check the the QLED docs
to see if these if it says anything
about the XCD. Can you do a graph
on the city in the in the Cubelet
docs?
So
Cubelet
and do a write city. Right? Oh, sorry.
Graph.
Okay. There are a lot of things here.
This
from now. Right?
I'm not sure. Yeah. But it's
just
Oh, it's trying to to system. Yeah. The
last error. It says dial TCP.
The less oh, the less error that isn't
syncing port. Right? Enable to write in.
Status for call, it says.
It's region giant form control plane dial. It's
timing out to dial against
Can I do But it doesn't it doesn't
need it doesn't need Selum to start, right,
because it connects to the API server directly?
Yeah.
Yeah. I think so.
What is that IP? 139.
Because the the XCD doesn't doesn't need to
connect to the API server. Correct?
So it only starts and then the API
server It's the other way around. Right?
Yeah. The the okay. So why is it
not starting?
Try
try restarting the and
see if if we have any bots again.
I wanna see if it starts and and
then goes away or something.
So I should do that really
fast. Right?
It's
So If if any pods would appear,
the the logs would be on the on
the directory,
but it isn't. Yes. It should be there.
Yeah. We don't have any tripods. So it's
not even starting.
Can we check the manifests again
on the
Kubernetes
manifest?
Yes. On the chat? No. We need some
help, folks.
Do we have hints for this? Maybe
Yeah. We have. We have. I saw that.
We have version.
So, yeah, let's use some kits. Check the
first hint here.
Bring your binary. Yeah. That makes sense. Makes
total sense.
Hints too.
Network.
Yeah. That's probably the result of comp.
Hosts thing.
It was open. Why is there a Oh,
the flash the IP tables. Amigo.
You're gonna straighten the flash? You don't even
want a look at them?
Yeah. Let let's do it.
Oh, there are dash.
Drop. Drop. Drop. Drop.
Okay.
So
Yeah. S t p four, API server port.
Just drop, drop, drop.
IP tables?
Dash f, capital f.
Type I IP table.
Yeah. Then we need to restart
everything. Right? Like No. No.
Restart a guildet, and that's it.
But I but I
don't have access to the machine now.
Oh, we've lost access. Yeah.
This didn't happen in the past.
Okay.
So
Let's see if can create another session.
I'm not sure. Right? Alright. Let's go for
it. Go over it at.
It's no longer active.
You're on the right.
It's gone.
Maybe we so we we lost the machine?
Alright. Let's see if we can get in
another way.
So
mhmm.
Okay.
Then just restart it, I think.
Restarting Restarting bare metal is not a fast
process.
It's
not a fast process. But then restarting it
could also
I don't wanna do things that they did,
so that's not that funny also.
We have
we have lost access.
So let's take us through. All we did
was a flush of IP table.
So
not even not even SSH light works, David?
Okay. It's not even SSH.
How long does it take to restart? It's
not it's not feasible. Ten minutes.
Ten minutes. I
have
console access.
The trouble is the root password is only
available for twenty four hours, and I'm pretty
sure I'd be on that.
I don't know if I keep it in
my Pulumi code. I can definitely check.
But that's funny. Why can I I think
it was trash for the
prevent us from access?
It depends what has been done with the
network.
Yeah.
Mhmm.
No. No. Maybe it's configured to drop everything
that isn't
there, and
it could be that.
Yeah. Let's see. I'm seeing if there's anything
we can do in the worker nodes, but,
yeah,
we can't do anything pretty much.
For the policy
the policy for forwards drop, the follows for
inputs drop. So, yeah, that's it.
Okay. So the machine is still alive at
least.
But I don't think I
export the
password.
One forty five. Okay.
And I believe that's where we
we made it.
Yeah. We didn't even start the Kube API
server. Okay.
Yeah.
I I don't have access to the password
to go in over the serial console anymore.
So I'll tell you what, I'll reboot it,
but I I just I don't know how
long that's gonna take to come back out.
Do you wanna give it five minutes maybe?
Maybe we can if you want, David, in
the meantime, we can show what we need
to break the other cluster if we have
time. I don't know how much time you
have.
Yeah. It's
So seems why is I mean, Teleport
is still running. Right?
Oh, yeah. Because I saw this on machine.
No. It's not connecting. No. Okay. Alright. Let's
reboot it.
Let's at least try.
How much time do you have left?
I mean, I I I don't mind I
don't mind going over. It's not a big
deal. It's just
we'll see what happens. We should be able
to see the machine reboot at least from
the studio console so we can keep an
eye on it.
But I I I just can't
I don't know what the flush why that
would
I think it's because of the default policy
for input is that's it. Right?
of the input chain. Right?
If it's on drop,
I'd say that you do because I I
flush IP tables all the time on custard.
It's it's
normally safe.
Normally.
I I don't know what's happened there.
Giant form says they don't believe that that
was them.
Let me well, we can try trashing the
IP tables on our control page to see
if it happens the same. Right? Yeah. Go
for it.
I'm gonna try that right now. I'll open
a session. Don't don't do the the on
the control plane because our also lost the
cluster. Oh, you are correct. You won't have
don't wanna work or so we can show.
Yeah.
Alright. I've opened a session on
worker one.
Okay. I'm gonna join in there. Wildlife Studios
works. Joining
there.
Okay.
You can see my screen. Right? Yep. Yep.
Mhmm. I'm here.
And I think that's
f. Yeah. I'm synchronizing to the machine. Right?
So Giant Swarm did something weird. I don't
know what they did, but
it works here.
Well, our machine is now at
BIOS bit stage. So hopefully, we get this
back in a minute or two, hopefully.
And I I'm going to change all my
automation to keep a track of the root
password so that we can actually get on
the machine. Dash
l. Right?
So here,
our our input policy for the the policy
for the input change
accept,
and on the on the their machines is
dropped.
Oh, they remain the full policy. That's why
Yeah.
Yeah. When we flush it,
the the full policy for the input chains
dropped, so we just get dropped.
That's what
Yeah.
I I still have the
my tab open
with the logs of the
Oh, yeah. That's right.
So what did you see here?
On the chain inputs, it's the first one
that should appear. It you'll see that on
the,
oh, see see here. The policy drop. So
everything there isn't listed there is going to
be dropped.
When we flush it,
now there is no there is nothing. So
it's going to get dropped.
But it's only port six for port three.
Right?
No. We we we
that that was as an explicit drop,
but everything that isn't there will also get
dropped.
Right? I I think that's the I'm not
very acquainted with IP table, but I think
that's the way that it works.
Machine is coming up.
Yeah. It's getting there because system do you
start in there? So we're just we're just
we're not far away.
Nice. Almost there.
In fact, we may
we may actually be okay. We're very close.
Yeah. That's it.
SSH
route transform control plan.
I see. Is getting connection refused?
It's almost there. We're just waiting for teleport
to get help or maybe
Oh, it takes a while, okay, to start
everything.
I have ten more minutes to spare, so
let's try to see if we can finally
get everybody.
Hey. Come on. Control plane.
It's annoying that I have a login prompt,
I don't know the root password.
Well, you always learn something new. Right? Oh,
yeah.
It's an iterative process.
I will.
I'm never going to dismiss that root password
again.
I I don't think we're gonna get access
again. Teleport should have started by now.
Okay. So if you want, David, we can
use these last minutes to show the people
the configuration of our cluster. I don't know
if it's worth it or
we can just call it for today.
Yeah.
Show us what you did, and then we'll
call it quite fresh. Okay? There there's just
there's just too much networking badness from from
my blood.
These are these are both cruel cruel teams.
Alright.
There's a session on your control plane, Wildlife
Studios control plane one. Show us what you
did, and then we'll we'll wrap up. We'll
we'll we'll try that we'll try that machine
again before we do it.
It sounds good.
So do you wanna show, Leo?
Or I guess. I'm already there. I can
do Okay.
Let me join too. You
are watching. Right? Yeah.
I'm already I already did.
Nice. So, basically, what we did
oh, I mean, I've been already. Yes. So,
basically, what I did is, like, if you
do
oh, let me export.
So if you do as I as we
said in our
in our introduction,
if you do
cube cube system,
you check the demo set, it's gonna be
scaled down. Right? So Selium wasn't working. However,
the nodes are showing as ready, right, even
though Selium is not ready. So what we
did in order to fool, basically, the queue
that that the node is ready, We actually
created a configuration in at at ECnet.d.
No. It's not in c. It's Oh, c
n I. C n I. Yeah. Right? So
we created this Cilium config list,
basically,
fake configuration file,
and we are fooling the the QLED that
the node actually has been working enabled
when in reality,
is not working. Right? So that's why the
nodes show up as ready.
So what we need to do to fix
this is, basically, we need to edit the.
We
need to what we need to disable is,
like, we only
change the
the affinities. Right? So this should be Linux
instead of AMP.
If if you check the demo set, the
scripture is gonna say that it doesn't basically
match the affinity. Yeah. We can't see that
because of the weird bug on this CLI.
But
So
now that Tilium is running,
what the the next step from here was
basically to exec into a Tilium bot. Right?
So
I can pick a Pod here,
like
this one,
and then
I can do key system.
Then it takes the bot name,
and then you can do a search here.
Batch, maybe? No. You need to
dash dash before the s h. Right?
No. You don't have to. Oh, no. No.
No. You have You don't have to. Yeah.
Maybe I'm executing the wrong bot. Let me
maybe I'm it's still checking on the old
ones. Yes. I believe I'm checking on the
old ones. So let me grab another code,
this one, the short names.
For this one.
And let's do watch.
Okay. Now I'm in the Serum pod, and
you need to do Serum
status.
Serum
basically, you have the
basically, Serum is gonna show everything here.
And if you did, like, Serum
endpoint service
list.
Yeah. You can do also the endpoint list.
Exactly. Only
API server,
and I
don't know what the service is, are basically
registered in. Right? So it it is missing
the cluster
the cluster service. And the reason why it's
missing the cluster service,
it is because we changed a configuration file
in Cilium
in the config map.
Cube system.
That is this one. It's Cilium Cilium config.
Dash config. Yeah.
It's basically
we only told Cilium to Yeah. It's just
that one. That's
what I'm You can delete it. Or
Yeah. Basically, this this basically tells Cilium to
only apply on the services that have have
the specific layout. So you remove this.
You re redeploy the app, basically. Let's do
I I don't know if I need to
touch the services to
cluster.
Cluster it.
Let's change, I don't know, annotation.
Let's do macros.
This
so the service basically gets modified. And now
if we exec again into the Serum pods
and
we do Serum
endpoint
Endpoint. Serum service. Serum You
didn't
yeah. It raised the endpoint.
Right.
Service list.
I think you it's
you need to re yeah. You need to
start setting because it changes this con the
config map.
K.
We did Pods
in cube system
with the label. Ecosystem.
You must have system.
You must have name. Oh,
Oh, nice.
K.
To the postache,
and this should be it. Let me exec
again into the port.
This one.
Serb
service
Service service.
As you can see, now everything should be
working. Yep. That's it. Alright. I mean, we
two members of giant swarm of us now,
so I'm gonna pop over to
camera mode. Oh, it's you need to restart
the deploy. But after that, everything is should
be working.
Alright. Great,
Giant Swarm.
Why did that flush destroy the world?
Good game, mate. So,
basically, we we've we also enabled
a a UFW
firewall.
Okay. By
default,
sets everything to deny other than things that
we've automatically allowed.
We set an allow in place for Teleport,
but you flushed it.
Mhmm.
So
yeah.
Yeah. That went away. Do
you want us to go through the other
things that we we tackle? Yeah. I was
going to ask exactly that. How much
were we missing to finish?
I So I have to drop guys.
Sorry. I'm it's getting late for me, but
it's been an amazing experience. No worries. Thank
you, Markus. Bye. I'll catch up with the
recruiter later. Thank you. Have a good one.
Take care. Cool.
Yeah. So you caught the first one with
the the kube control
binary.
So we we we didn't even replace the
one that was there. We just
curled down the the macOS one and put
it earlier in the path, basically. Oh, okay.
We didn't do anything with VIM. Didn't touch
that at all. What happened in the host's
file is we just put a load of
space. So the the host names that we
had were off the page.
And then and we then disabled Vim's
line wrap in the Vim RC so that
you won't see it unless you yeah.
It's Sneaky. See.
Very sneaky.
Yeah. I I was I was quite happy
with that one.
So you you caught the the service
side arrange, which was good.
What
you didn't catch, the issue with
etcd,
was we changed the host network from true
to false in the static pod. So
it was running on the host network.
That's why I was looking for a network
plugin, which wasn't there. Okay.
The other change we did was in API
server. We changed the port that the API
server was listening on, but didn't change the
the admin dot config, kubect config, and and
everything else.
So if if you'd have got etcd up,
you'd have probably So that's why there was
the IP table rules for 8443
and for 6443.
Yeah. Exactly. Yeah.
So, yeah, we had the IP table so
that you couldn't access it locally. We had
the UFW
so that the other worker nodes couldn't access
it. Mhmm.
Okay. The
final thing we did is we messed with
the core DNS
core file.
Oh, the core file. Okay. Yeah. So in
there, we added an ACL block to prevent
to block type a lookups,
which if you'd have looked, I think you'd
have probably caught that one. The one that,
was a bit sneakier
was in the Kubernetes,
cluster dot local block.
We added in,
namespaces all
in there.
Now name now all is not a keyword
in that case. That will actually match the
and and namespace called all and will only
serve all post names for that.
Oh, that that would pass this classic look.
That would pass the I test, wouldn't it?
You would oh, yeah. Yeah. I was I'm
quite proud of that one.
The the fight the just the final thing
that we did, well, we covered our tracks
by doing a touch on the entire file
system so that everything has the same enhancement.
So you could see what we what we
changed or anything like that.
Sneaky. Sneaky. Sneaky.
Yeah. We we messaged very little with the
file system. We only added that file that
that message with continuity thinking Kubernetes thinking that's
the node already, but it wasn't. But yeah.
So we That was a good one. That's
Yeah.
That was the first thing that we thought
on how to how can we disable Cilium
and make the the node fix it's ready,
but it isn't.
Yeah. So we we have no experience with
Cilium, so we we were never gonna get
that.
Next up, learn more about Cilium. Yeah.
Yeah. That's on our to do list now,
I think.
Alright. Well, user both evil evil teams.
So thank you for taking part in custard.
I hope you enjoyed that, and I'll see
you all again soon. Enjoyed
a lot. Thanks for the opportunity, David. Yeah.
Bye. Bye. Bye.